- Taco temple can I take your order
yeah hi how are you doing I like one
King quesadilla some steak tacos euros
hold on man okay I got that
ah grande rice pudding taco with the
chocolate shell of Coco girls know what
Jose - tros - chop alright I just
ordering okay this is the only thing I'm
good at don't take this away from me
like you take away everything else what
the hell are you talking about guys
let's not fight okay I'll tell you what
the hell I'm talking about you think
humans are stupid okay are you ever
doing all over my planet oh I drove for
seven hours to show you the Grand Canyon
and you mean pretend to be interested
oh the crack in the ground Jeff I mean
our planet we fix those guys can we
please please stop fighting was it that
like eight months ago how are you still
holding on to this stuff I'm holding on
to it because I actually have feelings I
like you guys a bunch of cold-blooded
Nazi oh here we go again with the Nazis
that's right here we go just compare
everything you don't like two Nazis jazz
lazy of course you'd say that
everything seems lazy to a Nazi I'm
sorry I'm having trouble understanding
you did you say you wanted three Oh we
want to kill you
yeah